hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm
Dave Rubin but you can call me Carlos
danger we have a great show for you this
week did you hear about the Royal baby
did you hear there's a baby a royal baby
can you believe it I've got two great
guests for you jr. Jackson from the TYT
all-star team making his first
appearance on the Reuben report
I'm just trying welcome to the show and
first time you were the first time to
peep guests you are now the first time
three-peat guests miss Kelly Carlin is
right here chief executive Ryan yes
there's never been a back-to-back in
second I guess but maybe if you guys
impress enough we could be really
impressed today we can we could make it
maybe it can be pulled up all right so
let's get right to it the big news of
the week the Royal baby and that of
course pushes everything else out of the
way Kate Middleton and Prince William
they had a kid the kid is now more
powerful and richer than you will ever
be and CNN and all the other news
organizations want you to know that the
coverage has been endless and it's gonna
it's gonna continue even this morning
CNN had on their Chiron that uncle what
sues the uncle the Uncle Harry he plans
on being a responsible but fun uncle so
yeah we've seen the poop I don't know
all right so there's a lot of ways we
can go at this but let's just start with
the general thing what is our obsession
as Americans with the royal family it
seems a little ludicrous considering we
left England originally because we
didn't want to be under the auspices of
a royal family I have theories about
this give me a theory so my theory is is
that a we are a little jealous you know
so our celebrities are royalty now in
this country but I really do believe
that you know kind of archetypal II we
have this King Queen thing that we want
to have a relationship with and they fit
right in and it's like oh look there
they are we can have that and in America
we can kind of have our cake and eat it
too you know what I mean it's like we
don't have to have any Royals we get to
borrow the Royals if we like it right
but we sort of treat our presidents now
and especially Obama as
right it was I guess what's our benefit
in doing it at least our benefit and we
have a royalty of course there's the
Bush family that have been that is yeah
I mean went from from HW to W possibly
Jed and and then Jeb I'm sorry yeah yeah
family it's definitely a jet yeah
and now wait yeah and then so then we
then we push our Clintons we had a
Clinton and then it hiccup for a second
but we might bring the next one back
yeah it's it's more things where we out
we have to we have to have this
connection to the same group to fill
this reverence to and we do which is our
politicians in general which is why
politicians can't do anything human and
messed things up because like well
you're a politician yeah that's fine but
we see this royal family is immaculate
perfect and we love the pomp and
circumstance you know we do we have our
flag waving and the Jets coming by and
you get all misty-eyed and and you know
and there's a lot of angle files in this
country but the amount of cover I
literally I tweeted yesterday because I
was like I went onto CNN like this like
barely like okay let's check it out
and I watched about 30 seconds so it was
like a mouse who they claimed was their
royal correspondent this is CNN who also
closed their Baghdad bureaus so that
tells you really that tells you a lot
about what yeah I'm of two minds of this
because on one hand it seems crazy you
know you're just this is just this rich
family that is taking and taking and
taking from society and while they have
all kinds of economic problems there as
we do here and then on the other hand I
think there might be something good
about it because they get to get out the
cult of personality on these people
where we want Obama to not only be a
president and function and do stuff but
also be our hero so I kind of think it
might be good do you do you buy that
theory a little bit does that make any
sense to you that maybe they get some of
their gossip stuff out all the stuff
that we push you know we want Obama to
be this perfect man and play basketball
perfectly and speak properly and be
funny where they get some of the cult of
personality all that personal stuff out
the royal family because they don't
really have jobs so they can you know
that way their Prime Minister can focus
on actually working some importance on
them because they don't do much I guess
the situation I mean at least we have a
dual use of our leaders in our oil
here's the thing that I find is really
interesting about this particular royal
family is that I've watched an amazing
documentary about them and when they
when Queen Elizabeth was raised her
father said to her if we are gonna have
any purpose in this culture we have to
be of service to to this country she was
trained from day one every single day
she is of service she goes out into the
community and does something and they
and they do try to raise their people up
and they do try to connect with them and
in a in a very connecting people way and
although they're rich and they got all
that land and all the jewels and all
that kind of stuff in it and it's a
fairy tale big castle full of gold that
they swim in that oh yes I think in some
ways they're it's like a more tangible
service that they're in with their
people than even our own politicians who
it becomes all about politics and taking
sides and now it's ridiculous because
nothing works right I think they hold
kind of a vacuum or an interesting kind
of a place where there's a space where
they actually can be idealized in some
way you know so I think you're kind of
right about the cult of personality
would that work for us do we need to
take away some power from these guys for
a power-hungry and then control our life
a lot of the more fatigue your heads
that are controlled by other powers
anyway those are hidden yeah right so
out right there it's a little more out
front so so last thought on this and
this is where you were touching on
earlier why is it that our media and
this goes to a much bigger problem that
you know we've had three weeks of
non-stop 24 hours immerman coverage fine
then we've had Royal baby coverage for
the last two days and then yesterday
amazingly the Royal baby got knocked off
because of Weiner slash or dick
basically why can't we balance two
things at once I don't want to
completely dismiss the importance of a
royal baby okay it's fine but why can't
we do a little of that and a little this
we have to do 24-hour coverage of
everything because we're a bunch of
Schmucks
the source attention span of anyone all
know if this spreads to also British
folks and when they have their coverage
I'm sure their coverage is just as
insane
yeah but I think the only way that there
one reason we have this one track -
because that's what we've been pushed
and then they form our brains if they
give us two things our brains will learn
to adapt right maybe we can absorb and
and and consume two things at once and
actually thoughtfully put it through our
brains but until we get it we're not
gonna be able to handle it yeah do you
agree do you think it's just a fetus
crap so we just steep crap pretty much I
think the structure of media is a
corporate structure it's all about
ratings
it's not about informing people so this
is what we get yeah do you guys remember
there was apparently a revolution in
Egypt a couple weeks ago we were gonna
have a no-fly zone in Syria
did you know Detroit went bankrupt but
there's a royal baby the story of that
day the day when the baby was born not
unborn unnamed baby the baby was unborn
that's all I really hope his name is
Gary yeah wouldn't help his name is
Lamar but the the biggest pet story
there was one of this I hate when people
say so while you guys are talking this
nonsense you know a real story happened
but that day there was a prison break at
Abu Ghraib and they got they released
500 prisoners with trucks backed in
explosives and RPGs and machine guns and
firefights I said this is like I mean if
anything this is a sensational stories
you can cover it and say usually this
badass fight Abu Ghraib
but didn't even do that but they didn't
do that right well I'll put a cap on
this by saying that I saw a tweet from
Anderson Cooper last night he was saying
coming up on a third ac360 and it was
royal baby
Anthony Weiner and a man who almost got
swallowed by a whale so that's what's
going on over there